The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The last lecture we consider
some basic structures
for infinite impulse
response and actually also
for finite impulse
response systems.
In this lecture, I would
like to focus specifically
on finite impulse response
systems and indicate, to show,
that for that class
of systems, there
are some structures
that specifically
exploit properties of
FIR, or finite impulse
response, systems.
First of all, let's
consider the general form
of a finite impulse
response system.
One of the characteristics of a
finite impulse response system,
of course, is the fact that
the impulse response has
only a finite number
of nonzero samples,
or equivalently the system
function involves a sum only
over a finite range.
So the system function in
general for a finite impulse
response system is of this form.
And the difference
equation for this system
is that the form of a sum from
k will 0 to capital N minus 1
of h of k, the unit sample
response, x of n minus k.
We've stressed the
fact, of course,
in a variety of the
earlier lectures,
that the difference equation
for a finite impulse response
system, in fact, corresponds
to the convolution
sum for finite impulse
response systems,
or the coefficients in
the difference equation
are, in fact, the values of
the unit sample response.
Now, for a finite
impulse response system
we can, of course, talk about
the same types of structures
that we talked about
in a previous lecture.
For example, we can generate
a direct form structure
from the difference
equation, or equivalently
from the z transform.
And we see that the direct
form structure corresponds
to generating a weighted
combination of delayed inputs
where the weighting coefficients
are the values in the unit
sample response h of n.
So for a general
direct form structure,
we have x of n, x of n minus 1
at the output of this delay, x
of n minus 2, et cetera, x of
n minus 1 multiplied by h of 1,
x of n multiplied by h of
0, down through the chain.
The results added
up at the output
to produce the
overall output y of n.
So this is what would
correspond to applying
the notion of a
direct form structure
to a finite impulse
response system.
Likewise, we could talk
about a transposed form
of this network.
We could also talk about
a cascade form realization
of a finite impulse
response filter,
simply by factoring
this into a product,
not a poles and zeros,
because, of course,
there aren't poles for a
finite impulse response system,
but as a cascade
of zeros, either
implemented as first or
second order sections.
Something to give some
thought to incidentally
is whether for a finite
impulse response system
you can generate a
parallel form structure
like the parallel form structure
that we talked about last time.
The answer to that,
in fact, is no.
And it's tied to
the fact that an FIR
system doesn't have any poles.
Although as we'll see
later on in this lecture,
there is a structure that is
of the form of a parallel form
for implementing FIR systems.
So the first point
then is that we
can apply many of the ideas
of the previous lecture
to FIR systems.
But in addition, there are some
properties of some FIR systems
that lead to some specific
network structures that
in general can't be used
for implementing IIR,
or recursive, systems.
The first of these that
I'd like to talk about
is directed specifically
toward the implementation
of linear phase FIR systems.
Now recall from
several lectures ago--
and we've again raised this
point a number of times--
that one of the differences
between IIR and FIR systems
is that because of the fact that
the impulse response of an FIR
system is a finite
length, those systems
can in fact be designed to
have exactly linear phase,
whereas the corresponding
statement of course
is not true for the case of
infinite impulse response
systems.
In particular, a linear phase
finite impulse response system
is one for which the values
in the unit sample response
satisfy a certain symmetry
condition, namely the symmetry
condition as I've
indicated it here,
h of n equal to h of capital
N minus 1 minus little n,
where capital N is the length
of the finite length impulse
response.
For example, a finite, a linear
phase FIR impulse response
as one example might look,
as I've indicated here,
where I've drawn it for
capital N equal to 9.
And this symmetry
property says that h of 0,
if I substitute n equals 0,
is equal to h of capital N
minus 1, or h of 8.
And we can see that that's
the symmetry that we have.
And then likewise, the
linear phase property
says that as I go through
the impulse response
from both ends, I
see identical values
so that these values
are identical.
Then these values are identical.
These, and, of course, this
one is identical to itself.
And that then is the general
symmetry of a linear phase FIR
impulse response.
Well, in fact, to stress once
again that the phase is indeed
linear, we can consider
generating a unit sample
response or impulse response
h1 of n, which corresponds
to this unit sample
response shifted
so that it's centered around
the origin, in which case h of n
is equal to h1 of n
plus capital N minus 1.
Or in this case, h of n is h1
of n shifted to the right by 4.
And consequently, the
frequency response
for this system, or the Fourier
transform of the unit sample
response is the Fourier
response of this system
multiplied by e to the j omega
capital N minus 1 over 2.
That is just due to the fact
that these two unit sample
responses are related to
each other by a linear shift.
Now, this unit sample
response is even.
That is it's even
about n equals 0.
And consequently,
its Fourier transform
is a real function of omega.
So this is real.
And consequently,
the phase associated
with the causal system h of n
is just simply this linear phase
term, e to the j omega
N minus 1 over 2.
So this is an
argument, again, that
stresses the fact that
if the unit sample
response has this symmetry,
then the phase of the system
is linear.
Now, how can we exploit
this in the implementation
of finite impulse
response systems?
Well, let's look, first of
all, at the general expression
for the z transform
of the system,
h of z given by a sum of
h of n z to the minus n.
And essentially the idea
in exploiting this symmetry
for the implementation
of FIR systems
is to take advantage of the
fact that because roughly half
of the values in h
of n are identical,
we should be able to implement
the system with essentially
only half the
number of multiplies
that would be required in
a more general FIR system.
Well, to show how
this works, let's
work through this
for the case where
we assume that
capital N, the number
of non-zero points in the
unit sample response, is even.
In the previous example, we'd
considered capital N odd.
Here, in working
through this let's
assume that capital N is even.
And a similar
derivation would apply
and has gone through in
the text for capital N odd.
OK, well, we can express
the transfer function h of z
as a sum from n equals 0
to capital N over 2 minus 1
of h of n z to the minus n--
those are the first half points,
the first half of the non-zero
points--
plus the sum over
the second half
of the non-zero points from
capital N over 2 to capital
N minus 1.
And basically where
we want to get to
is to exploit the fact that
these points are numerically
equal to these, except
that the index runs
in the other direction.
Well to develop that formally,
let's manipulate this sum
by using a substitution
of variables.
In particular, let's make
the substitution of variables
that r is equal to capital
N minus 1 minus little n,
or equivalently that little n
is equal to capital N minus 1
minus r.
If we do that,
then changing this
to a summation on r, where
we have that little n
is equal to capital N over 2,
little n equal to capital N
over 2, r is equal to
capital N over 2 minus 1,
as I've indicated here.
And when little n is equal
to capital N minus 1,
little r is equal to 0.
So this gets converted
to a sum from r equals 0
to capital N over 2 minus 1.
h of what was n, which
is now capital N minus 1
minus r substituted in here.
And then capital N minus 1
minus r again substituted
for little n.
Basically, what we've
done is reduce this
to a sum over the same
limits as we have here
and with the indices running
in the opposite direction.
And now, we can recognize
that because of the symmetry
property, because of
the fact that we're
talking about a linear
phase system, h of capital
N minus 1 minus r
is equal to h of r.
That's the symmetry
property that
corresponds to stating that
the system is linear phase.
All right, well, so here
we have a sum from n
equals 0 to N over 2 minus 1.
Some things involving h of n.
Here we have a sum from r
equals 0 to N over 2 minus 1,
some things involving h of r.
This index of
summation, of course,
is just a dummy variable.
And we can change it back to
n if we want to, which we do.
So rewriting these two sum,
in particular rewriting
this one in terms now
of a summation on n,
this becomes the
sum from n equals 0
to capital N over 2 minus 1, h
of n z to the minus capital N
minus 1 minus little n.
This sum, of course,
stays the same.
And now, because we
have h of n appearing
in both of these sums, we
can combine this together
into a single summation, from 0
to N over 2 minus 1 of h of n,
the values in the
unit sample response,
times z to the minus n
plus z to the minus capital
N minus 1 minus little n.
Notice now that we only
have in this summation
half the terms that
we had originally.
In other words,
there are capital N
over 2 different
coefficients that we're
using, whereas in the
direct form implementation,
there were capital N
coefficients that we
were using.
And here, we're exploiting the
symmetry in the coefficients.
Well, let's see
what this implies
in terms of a filter structure.
Here, I've simply
rewritten, again,
the general form for the
transfer function assuming
that the system is linear phase,
as we've just previously worked
out.
This is just simply a rewrite
of the previous expression.
And let's look at
this, for example,
I had assumed that that
capital N was even.
So let's choose as
an example capital
N equal to 8, in which case this
expression becomes a sum from n
equals 0 to 3, h of n, z to the
minus n plus z to the minus--
capital N minus 1 is
7, so minus 7 minus n.
Well, how many delays are
involved in implementing
this system function?
Apparently, there are seven
delays involved whether or not
the system is linear phase.
And that shouldn't be
surprising because the length
of the impulse
response is still 8.
So seven delays in
general are required,
but only four
coefficients are required.
And to see what structure
is implied by this,
we recognize that h
of z is constructed
by summing a system which
corresponds to a delay.
Looking at this expression
for n equal 0, no delay.
n equal 0 substituted in gives
us a transfer function of 1.
Plus a delay with n equal
0 substituted in of 7.
The output of those two delays
added together and multiplied
by h of 0, and consequently, if
we consider a chain of delays
as I've drawn here,
we have the output
before we go through
any delays added
to the output from
the seventh delay--
that's looking at this
expression for n equal 0--
and the result of that
summation multiplied by h of 0
to form the first
term in this sum.
To form the next term in
the sum for n equals 1,
we have the output of
one delay plus the output
from the 7th minus 1th delay.
That is the 6th delay.
So we have this output, the
output from the first delay,
and this output, the
output from the 6th delay.
And now that is multiplied
by h of 1 coefficient, which
is h of 1, to form the
next term in the sum.
And if we go through the
remaining terms in the sum,
we have the output from the
2nd delay and the output
from the 5th delay
added together.
That multiplied by h of 2.
The output from the 3rd
delay and the output
from the 4th delay
added together
and that multiplied by h of 3.
That forms the individual
terms in this sum.
And now we want finally
to add those together.
So we can simply
add those together
at their outputs to
form the output y of n.
So here is a structure
which implements
a finite impulse response system
of order 8, or of length 8.
It involves seven
delays, which of course
the direct form also involves.
But the important
aspect of it is
that it involves only half
the number of multiplies
that the direct form
would normally require.
Taking advantage of the fact
that it's a linear phase system
then, we're able to
implement the system
with half the
number of multiplies
than would be
required in general.
All right, so this
is one structure.
I stress again that it's not the
only structure for implementing
a linear phase system.
Clearly, we can generate
another structure, linear phase
structure, by simply applying
the transposition theorem
to this structure.
And we would end up with a
transposed configuration.
And an example of that
is shown in the text.
I won't bother going through it.
But the important aspect here is
that we were able to exploit--
in the case a finite
impulse response systems
we're able to exploit the
linear phase characteristics
of the system, if we're
talking about a system that
is linear phase.
The second structure that is
peculiar to find an impulse
response systems and in some
instances has some advantages
is a structure that is often
referred to as a frequency
sampling structure.
The reason for that being
that the coefficients
in the structure correspond
to samples of the frequency
response of the system.
And I'll indicate
in a few minutes
why that might be an advantage.
But first let's look at
what the specific structure
is that's involved.
A frequency sampling
structure is
derived by essentially
implementing the system,
or inquiry as to what the
implementation would be,
if we specify the system in
terms, rather than of the unit
sample response, of the discrete
Fourier transform coefficients.
We recall, and I hope that this
is second nature to you by now,
in general we have a
unit sample response.
This is a finite
impulse response system.
So this is a finite
length sequence.
So we can describe it in
terms of it's discrete Fourier
transform.
And the discrete Fourier
transform coefficients
are referred to as h of k.
Or we can describe
it as we can describe
almost all sequences in
terms of its z transform,
or a system in terms
of its system function.
The z transform is the
sum of h of n times
e to the minus, n
as it always is.
And the unit sample
response can be
expressed in terms of
the discrete Fourier
transform coefficients
in terms of the sum of H
of k W sub N to the minus n k.
We have the 1/N out in front.
And again, this term
R sub capital N then
to just simply truncate h
of n after capital N points.
That is to extract one period
from the periodic function
that this sum generates.
Now, we can substitute
h of n expressed
in terms of its discrete Fourier
transform into this expression.
The R sub N of n will
disappear because we're only
summing from n equal 0
to capital N minus 1.
And if we substitute
this in here
and interchange the order in
which we evaluate the sums,
then the resulting
expression for the z
transform for the
system function
is the sum from K equal 0 to
N minus 1 of the DFT values.
And this term and this term
are involved in the sum on n.
And they result in the sum from
0 to capital N minus 1 of z
to the minus 1, W
capital N to the minus k.
That raised to the n-th power.
Well, this is the
kind of summation
that we've been carrying out
again and again, particularly
in talking about finite
length sequences.
And hopefully, this is
another kind of summation
that by now you carry
around in your hip pocket.
It's the sum from 0
to capital N minus 1
of something of the
form alpha to the n,
where the alpha
happens to be that.
And that sums up to 1 minus z
to the minus capital N times--
let's see, 1 minus z
to the minus capital N
and actually W sub capital
N to the minus k capital N.
That is it sums up
to this alpha raised
to the capital N-th power
divided by 1 minus W sub N
to the minus k times
z to the minus 1.
Well, what does W sub capital
N to any integer multiple
of capital N?
That's just simply
equal to unity.
So this term disappears.
And we end up simply
with 1 minus z
to the minus n divided by this.
All right, so combining
this together,
we can then express h of z as 1
minus z to the minus capital N,
we have this 1/N, which we
have to account for somehow,
and then finally a sum from
0 to N minus 1 of H of k,
divided by this factor.
And so this is an expression for
the z transform of the system,
or the transfer function
of the system, where
the coefficients
in that expression
are the discrete Fourier
transform values H of k.
The discrete Fourier
transform values,
as we've stressed
several times, in fact
are samples on the unit
circle of the z transform.
So these coefficients,
the H of k's are
in effect samples
of the frequency
response of the system.
In other words, they
are frequency samples.
And consequently, the
structure that this implies
is usually referred to as a
frequency sampling structure.
Well, let's look at what
the specific structure is.
We can view this as a cascade
of the system that implements
this term in cascade
with the system that
implements this summation.
This term is simply
implemented by a gain
of unity in the
forward direction,
and then a gain of minus
z to the minus capital N--
I happen to have the arrow here
in the reverse direction, which
is wrong.
This is as an arrow, again,
in the forward direction.
That just simply implements
the system, 1 minus z
to the minus capital N.
And that I guess makes
enough of a mess out of it,
so that hopefully you
can at least see what
direction that arrow goes in.
This then implements that piece.
To implement this
sum, well, this sum
implies a parallel
combination of systems,
each system implementing
one of these pieces.
So if we look at this,
say, for k equal 0,
we have a coefficient of 0 as
I've indicated here and a pole.
And where is the pole?
Well, the pole for k equal 0
is at W sub N to the minus 0.
For k equal to 1, it's
at W sub N to the minus 1
and on through.
So the system that
implements this sum is then
a parallel combination
of first order poles,
where the coefficient
in the feedback path
is W sub N to the minus k.
And the gain in
the forward path,
which can be placed either
before or after the pole,
are the frequency
samples H of 0, H of 1,
down through H of n minus 1.
And then, of course,
we have the gain
of 1/N, which has
to go someplace.
And for now, let's just
leave it at the end.
I stress also that
these, of course,
are complex poles, because
W sub N to an integer power
is in general complex.
We can, of course,
redraw this structure
by combining complex
conjugate poles together.
And the structure that results
is indicated in the text.
I won't bother to do that here.
But there are a couple of points
about this structure that I'd
like to draw your attention to.
First of all, we started with a
finite impulse response system.
Obviously, we've ended up with a
But the system appears
to have some poles in it.
That is its a
recursive structure,
and it has in fact
capital N poles
involved in the implementation,
although presumably
the overall system
function has only zeros.
Well, how can that be?
Very simply because if
you look at this term,
this term has capital N
zeros equally distributed
around the unit circle in angle.
And in fact, a zero
is occurring exactly
at the location where
each of these poles occur.
So that, in fact, this
piece in cascade with this
cancels out this feedback
loop, or this pole simply
cancels out one of the
zeros from this term.
This one cancels out
another zero and on down
through the chain.
So in the overall system
function, there are no poles.
There are only zeros.
And what happens in
effect is that these poles
are used to cancel out
different zeros appearing
in this first path.
That suggests one
of the problems,
in fact, with the frequency
sampling structure
because it requires poles, as
I've drawn it here actually
on the unit circle--
in an actual
implementation obviously
that would be slightly
of the unit circle--
but it involves
implementing poles
to cancel out the zeros
appearing in this term 1 minus
z to the minus n.
And that has some drawbacks
from a number of points of view.
In fact, it has some drawbacks--
we won't analyze
this, but it turns out
to be true that due
to finite register
length effects there
are some drawbacks.
But there are also
some advantages
to this kind of structure.
And the advantages
in some situations
outweigh the disadvantage,
the main disadvantage,
of canceling out zeros with
poles or poles with zeroes.
One of the first advantages
is that the coefficients
that are involved involve
frequency samples.
Now, in many situations what
we would like to implement
is a system in which perhaps a
large number of the frequency
samples happen to be zero.
Imagine for example,
implementing
a very narrow band, low
pass or bandpass, filter
and specifying the
filter in such a way
that the frequency samples
in-band are non-zero
and the frequency samples out
of band are equal to zero.
In that case, most
of the coefficients
are coefficients which
are zero coefficients.
And consequently, there will
be only a few of these paths
that we have to implement,
so that in that situation
where perhaps a large number
of frequency samples are zero--
in fact, the number of
multiplications involved
in implementing the system, and
in fact, the number of delays
involved in
implementing the system,
might be significantly reduced.
Another advantage to a
frequency sampling structure
is the fact that it is basically
a parallel form structure.
And that can be exploited
in terms of implementation
of a large number of filters, or
in terms of the implementation
of a filter bank.
Let me state more specifically
what I mean by that.
In this system function,
this piece and this piece,
except for the H of k's,
are tied only to the fact
that the unit sample
response of the system
is of length capital N.
So that if I implement
a large number of systems whose
impulse response is of length
capital N, the systems will
look identical from the input
up to the point where I do the
multiplication by the frequency
samples.
Consequently, if I were to
implement a large number of
filters simultaneously.
I can use in common for
all of those systems
the part of this
structure from the input
to the output of the poles.
And then simply draw
off those outputs,
multiply by the required
frequency samples,
sum the outputs, and that
implements the filter.
Consequently, I'm able
to share among all
of the filters in
the filter bank
these delays, these delays, and
the multiplications by powers
of W. And the only
additional coefficients
and the only additional
pieces that come in that
differ between the filters
and the filter bank
are the coefficients that I
multiply these outputs by.
I need to multiply
by the coefficients
and then form the
linear combination.
So that then are the two
primary advantages to frequency
sampling structures.
And in fact, frequency
sampling structures
have found application
primarily for those two reasons.
Well, there are lots
of other structures
that one can talk about,
both for a finite impulse
response an infinite
impulse response systems.
And as I stressed at the
end of the last lecture,
the discussion of
structures in general
and the kinds of structures that
can be generated is very vast.
In fact, it seems that new
structures are generated faster
than they can be evaluated.
And I would like to
terminate the discussion
of specific structures with just
the ones that I've shown you
in the previous
lecture and the ones
that I've shown for finite
impulse response systems
in this lecture.
To conclude that discussion
of digital networks
and digital filter
structures, I'd
like to focus
finally on just a few
of the issues, one
primarily, involved
in the comparison of
filter structures.
Now we've talked about
different structures.
One of the things
that obviously is true
is that from a strictly
mathematical point of view,
all of these structures,
different ways of implementing
the same transfer
function, obviously
implement the same
transfer function.
That is algebraically
or theoretically,
all of the structures from
an input output point of view
are indistinguishable.
In other words, they generate
the same transfer function.
On the other hand,
there are a variety
of issues when one considers
the practical implementation
of digital filters that have
to be considered in choosing
different filter structures.
One of them I suggested last
time to be the number of delays
involved.
And we saw the difference
between non-canonic and canonic
form structures.
Delays mean registers.
And registers mean hardware.
In talking about
linear phase filters,
we saw that if we exploit the
linear phase property, then
we can reduce the number
of multiplications
involved by half.
And multiplications, again, mean
hardware or speed or something
of that sort in terms
of the implementation.
Another common
characteristic that
can be focused on in
comparing structures
is what you could
refer to as modularity.
It's particularly important
in hardware implementation
of digital filters,
where perhaps you
would like your structure
to have stages in it that
are identical, so that
the implications in terms
of the hardware are that
a section or sections can
be multiplexed and therefore
used over and over again.
And another issue,
which is the one
that I'd like to direct
our attention to finally
are the effect of
finite register
length on the characteristics
of the system.
And these characteristics,
or the finite register length
effects, in fact, are very
heavily dependent on the filter
structures that are used.
There are two kinds of finite
register length effects.
One of them has to
do with the fact
that arithmetic in
a digital filter,
specifically in a
recursive digital filter,
has to be done, of course,
with finite register length,
and it has to be truncated.
In other words, multiplications,
the result of B bits times B
bits results in 2B bits.
If this goes on indefinitely,
obviously the register length
grows indefinitely.
And so the results
of arithmetic have
to be truncated or rounded.
And this generates some
noise or essentially
noise in the filter output.
And the second thing is
the fact that coefficients
have to be represented in
finite register length.
That is coefficients
or parameters
have to be truncated.
What I would like to do
in closing the lecture
is just briefly
give you a glimpse
into some of the issues of
the coefficient, or parameter,
quantization and not delve
any in any more detail
into the relatively complex
issue of finite register length
effects.
But let's focus just a
little bit, just a little,
on the effects of
parameter quantization.
In particular, we have, of
course, the general form
for a system function as a
ratio of polynomials in z
to the minus 1, where the
denominator polynomial,
as we've been writing
it, is of the form
1 minus the sum of a sub
k times z to the minus k.
Well, let's imagine that
what we would like to do
or that it's reasonable to tie
the investigation of H of z
in terms of parameter errors
to the accuracy, with which
the poles of the transfer
function can be placed.
We can express this polynomial,
the denominator polynomial,
in factored form, where, of
course, each of the factors
involves the poles of
the system explicitly.
And now as we talk about
implementing this system,
the coefficients in the
denominator polynomial,
and in the numerator
polynomial also,
have errors due to the fact
that they have to be represented
in a finite register length.
So we can represent that as the
coefficient that we actually
arrive at is the
coefficient that we really
want plus some error.
And consequently,
the pole location,
the location of each of
the poles, the i-th pole,
for example, is where we
want it plus some deviation.
Now, we can examine
what this deviation
is by essentially assuming
that the variation
in these parameters is small.
And expressing
this error in terms
of the partial derivatives of
the pole locations expressed
in terms of the
coefficients a sub k.
In other words, we can
express the movement
of the pole in terms of the
movement of the coefficients
as a sum of the
partial derivative
of the pole, the
i-th pole-- that's
the one we're talking
about here-- with respect
to the k-th coefficient
times the error
in the k-th coefficient.
Well, this can be
tracked through--
and this is done in the text.
I won't go through the algebra--
but basically, the result is
that this partial derivative
can be expressed in this form
where the important thing
to focus on is that what's
involved in the denominator
is the product of the difference
in the pole locations.
Let's assume, for example,
that all of the poles
are clustered inside a
circle of radius epsilon.
In other words, the largest
distance between the poles
is epsilon.
What that says then is that
when we substitute that
in for this expression,
the absolute value
of the change in the pole
location with respect
to a change in the coefficient
has in the denominator epsilon
raised to the n-th power.
Well, what does that mean?
What it means is that if
the poles are clustered
within a radius within a
circle of radius epsilon,
for any given pole the higher
the order of the polynomial
that we use to
implement the pole,
the greater the sensitivity of
the pole location with respect
to the coefficient.
So this says that
if we implement
the poles of the system,
or when we implement
the poles of the
system, it obviously
is better to implement the
poles through a lower order
polynomial rather than through
a higher order polynomial.
What does this mean
in terms of the filter
structures we've
been talking about?
It means basically that the
direct form structures are
the most sensitive, that the
cascade form structures are
certainly less sensitive than
the direct form structure,
and the parallel form
structure in terms
of the implementation
of the poles
have the same type
of hypersensitivity
as the cascade form
and likewise are less
sensitive than the direct form.
Even in the cascade
form structure,
though, there's
some flexibility.
And there are some
issues with regard to how
the poles are implemented.
And let me close the
lecture by just giving you
some indication of what some
of the-- in particular what two
of the possibilities might be.
Based on the discussion that
we've just gone through,
the indication is that we
would want to implement,
or it might be it advantageous
from the point of view
of parameter quantization, to
implement a system as a cascade
or parallel combination of
first or second order sections.
And let's make them
second order sections.
Let's look once again
at the implementation
of a simple second
order pole pair.
I've neglected the
implementation of the zeros.
But clearly the point
that I'm about to make
extends also for
the implementation
of two poles and two zeros.
Here, I have
implemented in what we
had referred to as direct form,
a second order section which
we might use in a cascade
form or parallel form
realization, which
implements the complex pole
pair at radius r, an angle
plus, and minus theta.
In the actual implementation
of a cascade or parallel form
structure using a second
order section of this form,
it is these
coefficients that are
quantized to fit within
a finite register length.
We see then that
the quantization
of the coefficients for
this particular network form
corresponds to quantizing
the parameter r squared
and quantizing the
parameter 2r cosine theta.
What this implies in the
z-plane is that for, let's say,
a choice of register length
for this particular case
equal to 3, for 3-bit
register length, the pole
locations which can be
implemented with that system
are restricted to fall at the
intersection of the grid points
that I've indicated
here due to the fact
that quantization of the
parameter r cosine theta
implies that we must lie
along lines equally spaced
along the horizontal axis.
Recall that r cosine theta is
just the real part of the pole
location.
And quantization
of the parameter r
squared corresponds
to the requirement
that the poles must
lie along circles,
which are spaced according to
the quantization of r square.
So the realizable pole positions
with a second order section
in the form that I indicated
on the previous slide
are given by the constellation,
or by the intersection
of the grid points,
that we have shown here.
Another possible implementation
for a second order pole pair
is the so-called coupled
form implementation.
I won't justify
here by inspection
that the transfer function is
given by the same expression as
for the direct form structure
that I showed previously,
but, in fact, it is.
And the poles in
this case fall at,
again, are equal to e
to the j theta and r
e to the minus j theta.
But now, the coefficients we see
are r cosine theta and r sine
theta.
Quantization of r cosine theta
implies, as it did previously,
that the poles must lie
along lines equally spaced
along the horizontal axis.
Quantization of r
sine theta implies
that the poles must line
along lines equally spaced
along the vertical,
or imaginary, axes.
And so for that case, the choice
of realizable pole positions
are governed by the
constellation of grid points
that I've indicated here.
So this is just simply,
this last issue,
is just simply an
introduction to the fact
that even given the notion that
the cascade form structure is
better than the
direct form structure,
there are additional issues
involved in specifically
how to implement a pole pair,
or a pole zero combination
in order to account for
parameter quantization effects.
There are lots of
remaining issues,
as you'll see in
the text, related
to both the issues of
digital filter structures
and the effects of parameter
and arithmetic finite register
length effects, which
we won't be going
into in this set of lectures.
But you should at least be aware
be aware of their existence.
In the next several
lectures, we'll
begin on a new topic,
namely a discussion
of some of the issues
involved in the design
of digital filters.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]